guys this was terrifying to watch
Nightline could not handle this movie
very well how do you guys handle scary
movies like is there a scary movie from
you that really freaks you out so I have
a tactic oh wait yeah no I'm a tactic
for scary movies um so I plug my my ears
with my thumbs and then I cover my eyes
with my pinky whoa in the movie theater
in the movie here as it is there is
there a specific movie that you did this
in it one okay it's still like this
movie still freak sure I guess right
yeah not really anything about the movie
we know you never want to sorta know
what just scenes but like we don't a lot
if we haven't seen the ants or scary
movie but you guys have seen it really
freaked you um oh man thank you sir no I
hereditary is pretty freaky done that
was pretty amazing film Devil Inside was
the one that did it for me just horrible
I wish I covered my eyes and ears in
soul
yeah so have you guys seen the movie yet
no oh you haven't see me yet no so what
do you think of these adult actors
playing you guys is that a weird thing
for you guys and me being is a special
human being I think he is wonderful and
he he'd I haven't seen much what he's
done with the role but I I think he did
an amazing job
I'm gonna just tell you that now I'll
say the same thing but you want to be
able to play all right yeah yeah that
was a big dream and it was crazy it
actually came true so it's pretty cool
yeah yeah yeah you would see Jessica
Chastain that's so good mister very
awesome very cool guy we're very similar
in actual life so it's kind of weird
passing someone very much like you and
he plays you
it's very cool yeah no fan I know if you
saw this poster hi Mendel did a fellow
Canadian you see do that
so crazy yeah it's like that's crazy how
much you guys look alike yeah except
hopefully I don't lose all my hair right
what that's not a dig it's tract but I'm
fine with that I'll be fine if I wait
thank you yeah what's crazy how much you
guys look alike
yeah now like I know this is the final
chapter this movie's gonna make a ton of
money so they somehow come I do seize it
yeah oh it's gonna make a lot of money
I'm sure but if there's they somehow
come up with an idea for chapter 3 would
you guys be game of course of course any
time I mean if we could be together
yeah back again I mean hopefully I I
don't I don't see I mean that's in more
of an any question but I don't know I
don't think there is meant to be a third
one it's not really another chapter you
can almost believe it to the Roger if
you'll let us work together again we
come back yeah
terms of endings like stranger things I
know uh four brothers have said that
this is seasoned force probably going to
be that or this that there yeah there's
like a there's no intended end yet but
like there's like they yeah I can't go
for way too much longer right like would
you be satisfied if it just season three
was the best season like oh yes I I'm
really proud of you
it depends on the ending honestly I
think like if if it caught like if the
season was really really good and it
calls for another season yeah
you